hey youtubers is charlie welcome to
emergency anime club episode 2 this time
we'll be talking all about Miyazaki
films I'll even be talking a little bit
about his newest film the wind rises so
let's do the giveaway stuff first then
I'll do my top 5 Miyazaki films and then
I'll do a short review of the wind rises
first things first congratulations to
David lesta and cherry Chan 29 you are
the two winners of my crunchy world
guest passes you're both going to get
one so I'll reach out to you on google
plus I also promised to pick one person
to choose a future topic for emergency
anime club so congratulations to nerdy
pajamas I'll be reaching out to you too
you get to pick a future topic any kind
of anime that you want to talk about and
then I'll work the video in and then
I'll just let everybody else know
whenever we're gonna talk about it this
week because we're talking all about
Miyazaki i'll be giving away one free
studio ghibli DVD to a random subscriber
in the comments if your international is
just going to be paypal equivalent so
here are my top 5 Miyazaki films of all
time number 5 princess mononoke this was
actually the first miyazaki film I ever
saw they screened it at my college and
it was the sub not the dub version I
didn't know anything about Miyazaki at
the time but I was so hypnotized by the
style and the story that I just started
looking for as many imports as I could
find it was also the movie that puts
Studio Ghibli on Disney's radar they
ended up releasing you know all the dvds
in the US which is why you have to sit
through those weird John Lasseter intros
number for my neighbor totoro I saw this
one much later and of all of Miyazaki's
films I feel like totoro is the most
identifiable character Essien in
Adventure Time the movie itself is one
of the smallest it takes place in this
tiny area around their house so there's
this really cozy feeling this is
actually the Miyazaki film that I
usually rewatch if I get super sick and
have to stay home number three spirited
away this was actually Miyazaki's first
international box office it it was the
highest earning japanese film ever at
the time since it was released only one
other jibley film has earned more money
I really like how urban it feels and the
bath house itself was a location that a
lot of other anime ended up paying
homage to later for all the core fans
out there during beginnings that scene
where all the animals travel to the
sacred spring is them doing their
version of the bath house all of
Miyazaki's films are really immersive
they really suck you in but this was
actually the first miyazaki film that I
saw that felt you know real to me like
it felt like a real world that I could
live in number two the wind rises be
careful if you don't like crying in
public
because this one will turn you into a
pile of sadness I'll talk more about it
in depth during my review but it has
this very ambiguous ending that really
challenges your perception of happiness
I made it my number two because all of
my favorite films you know really affect
me in intense emotional ways and with
all the crappy movies coming out of
Hollywood every year that doesn't happen
very often so whenever something can
make me cry in public it definitely
deserves a top three spot seriously I'm
almost crying right now just thinking
about it again and my number one
favorite Miyazaki film of all time
whisper of the heart this movie actually
used to be a really hard one to find
it's not as controversial as the wind
rises but it feels a lot more familiar
when Rises took place during World War
Two Japan so unless you are alive then
it's really hard to identify with the
world of that film whisper is just about
to normal kids and for me it felt very
autobiographical or biographical
depending on how you look at it meaning
a lot of the plot and themes felt
similar to things that had happened in
my life and that really helped me
connect with the characters on a really
deep level of all of Miyazaki's films
this is one of the few that doesn't have
any dubbed versions and that is exactly
the way it should stay it is completely
precious now since this is anime club
it's your turn right your favorite
Miyazaki film in the comments below and
let me know how you found your first
music II film did you see it in a
theater did a friend loan you a copy in
case you haven't seen it yet you need to
put the wind rises on your must-see list
in 2014 the movie gets a wider release
in late februari so you should all have
a chance to see it wherever you live the
main character is this really optimistic
engineer who invented the Japanese dive
our airplanes during World War 2 the
film itself is kind of about how
unfortunate circumstances can pervert
good intentions of all of Miyazaki's
films it's the most controversial just
because of the topic but it's also one
of his most tragic films just to give
you a warning before you see this movie
make sure you do something to make
yourself feel happy you will need a
buffer for the sadness thank you so much
for another emergency anime club next
week we'll be talking about the Sailor
Moon reboot be sure to subscribe to get
that video and watch some classic Sailor
Moon just so you have some context right
now click here for last week's anime
club and click here for my legend of
korra QA thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives